u.s president joe biden says the united
states and its allies are standing
united in the face of russia's
aggression toward ukraine in his first
state of the union address to lawmakers
biden said the ukrainians fight was an
inspiration to the world and that
russian president vladimir putin was now
more isolated than ever he pledged the
u.s would defend
its nato allies but again said that u.s
forces would not get involved in the
fighting
american diplomacy u.s analyst william
gluecroft is with me in the studio to
break things down william you're
watching the speech with me it wasn't
long before biden turned his attention
to ukraine and very much addressing the
room as the commander-in-chief yeah it
was definitely that the top line it had
to be right i mean this is a huge war
that's looking to upend uh european
security looking to upend a lot of
of the way we've
known life to be for at least the last
30 years in the post-cold war if not the
last 80 years since world war ii so this
is a huge huge issue that joe biden of
course has to confront and has been
confronting the last uh many weeks and
months and he had some tough talk to say
to vladimir putin i think we have a
quick
clip of of him having a message to the
russian president
putin's latest attack on ukraine was
premeditated
and totally unprovoked
he rejected repeated repeated efforts at
diplomacy
he thought the west and nato wouldn't
respond
he thought he could divide us at home in
this chamber in this nation
he thought he could divide us in europe
as well
but putin was wrong
we are ready we are united and that's
what we did we stayed united we prepared
extensively and carefully we spent
months building coalitions of other
freedom-loving nations in europe and the
americas to america to the asian and
african continents
to confront putin
like many of you i spent countless hours
unifying near our european allies
we shared with the world in advance what
we knew putin was planning and precisely
how we would try to falsify
and justify his aggression
joe biden in his first state of the
union address with him also announcing
getting specific on the toughening of
sanctions yes russia i think it's
accurate to say he's the sanctions
commander-in-chief we should be careful
he's not commander-in-chief because
america is not at war and we need to be
really careful with where we draw those
lines uh given the perilous state of
affairs right now but yes sanctions are
the go-to tool really the only tool that
the united states and its allies can
have short of military force which it's
not going to use directly although it
has made a lot of pledges to
humanitarian aid to military aid
including heavy weapons now for a long
time there's the question of so-called
defensive weapons it's a bit of a of a
murky uh definition of what a defensive
weapon is versus a non-defensive weapon
but we're talking about real heavy
weapons getting them to ukraine uh
forces if they can get them there given
the the
real uh violent situation on the ground
um and talking about uh closing airspace
uh to russian commercial aircraft over
the united states something that uh all
of the eu has already done i'm sure
there's gonna be a tit-for-tat with uh
russia probably closing its airspace to
american airlines um the question is
how much
will russia suffer and how quickly and
how much blowback will there be on the
us and other allies because obviously
there are economic partnerships here
there's financial partnerships here
the u.s and the eu are banking on that
they have enough money and enough
cushion enough support to be able to
protect their consumers and their voters
in ways that russia can't and we've
already seen the ruble crash we've seen
the moscow stock market or the russian
stock market closed we've seen runs on
the banks and these kinds of things an
important domestic topic for the
president how he's going to turn that
the issue of rising inflation in the u.s
how did joe biden go about reassuring
the american public
that while the economy is strong the
cost of living is going up right and
americans are not all convinced that the
economy is strong although there has
been good economic data since biden
became president
economy is just as much about how
someone feels in any kind of factual
numerical uh data you can see on a piece
of paper and that's something that biden
really tried to push home because the
economy is so important to winning
elections and so important to his
favorability rating as it is for any
president or any political leader really
and inflation has been very difficult
already before the russian innovation of
ukraine gas prices going up food prices
going up these kinds of things really
hitting the pocketbooks of average
americans and joe biden has to assure uh
americans that whatever action they take
against russia there will be a safety
net there so americans don't feel it and
i think we also have a clip of that of
something that joe biden was saying to
his
his voters
the panic also disrupted the global
supply chain
factories close
when that happens it takes longer to
make goods and get them to the
warehouses to the stores and go prices
go up
look at cars last year
one third of all the inflation was
because of automobile sales there
weren't enough semiconductors to make
all the cars that people wanted to buy
and guess what
prices of automobiles went way up
especially used vehicles as well but
and so we have a choice
one way to fight inflation is to drive
down wages and make americans poor
i think i have a better idea to fight
inflation
lower your cost not your wages
folks
that means make more cars than
semiconductors in america
more infrastructure and innovation in
america
more goods moving faster and cheaper in
america
more jobs where you can earn a good
living in america
instead of relying on foreign supply
chains let's make it in america
the words of the u.s president william
gluecroft there was a lot to digest
thanks for guiding us through joe
biden's first
state of the union address thank you